[Music]
foreign
if you have held out in getting the
brilliant Samsung s95b OLED TV I'm
hoping that you have some spare cash
left because right here is the updated
Samsung s95c OLED TV 42023 and it comes
at a huge 77 inches
even though it's still generally New Gen
Tech from Samsung V8 gig culture were
confident enough to give it our git
culture go Award for best display of
2023 do check out the links in the
description below so with the new TVs
being refreshed this year is the Samsung
s95c OLED TV the one to finally buy
without hesitation let's find out
Samsung has really thrown down has
Gauntlet at their competitors and having
achieved great success with the s95d
it's time to see if the s95c is a worthy
successor to the crown it's not about
getting it right the first time by
getting it right and perfected
consistently time and time again based
on our understanding and research it
looks like 2023's s95c is a TV to get if
you have the space and purchasing power
to do so
how can we be so confident
largely it's down to how brilliant this
TV is however I do have to say up front
that while the TV does really well in
terms of picture and sound the jump in
terms of performance will be comparable
to the s95b OLED TV which was released
last year 1K Omission is the absence of
Dolby vision and that's something new
Samsung fans will have to Grapple with
if you are looking to get this TV both
the s95c and s95d are great TV models in
their own right but if you can afford it
getting the biggest OLED TV Samsung has
to offer is something worth saving up
for the UI for the TV is once again the
biggest hurdle to Grapple with and is
something most consumers need to be
aware of before making the plunge
thankfully everything else is just coded
which blacks and an increased brightness
over the s95b is a fit that Samsung has
been able to deliver successfully that
in itself is an achievement that has to
be loaded
with that we are going to unravel all
the details in this video so do check
out the timestamps below but before we
do here's a message from all sponsor
this video is about to you by MSI meet
Summit e16 flip featuring the latest
12th gen Intel Core i7 processor RTX 30
series graphics and a 16 inch Quad HD
Plus touchscreen panel with a 360 degree
hinge it lets you unleash maximum
productivity with up to 11 hours of
battery life at just 2 kilograms the
Sami e16 flip offers unprecedented
performance and functionality allowing
you to work and play anywhere anytime
the back once again in the living room
and Samsung recommends with a TV this
size at 77 inches you're better off
having at least 2.3 meters of distance
in between where you're sitting to the
TV for maximum benefit
there's a big window to the left of the
TV and we'll see how it fares under this
lighting condition again from the
initial setup I was surprised that the
s95c is now able to Output at even
brighter levels with a larger display
based on research the s95c panel is able
to reach 1 600 nits sustained compared
to the s35b this is an improvement by
200 nits and in my use and feedback from
anyone who has seen this display it's a
bit too bright in fact for anyone out
there who genuinely avoided oleds for
the lack of brightness in some ways it
might be comparable to staring at a
floodlight with the s95c
even with increased brightness the
colors on this OLED TV continue to look
amazing and do not look washed out in
any way for Falls who like greater
control over the picture settings do
remember to turn off the intelligent
mode to get the most out of the TV with
the s35b we had in filmmaker mode but it
seems that Samsung has kept things more
simple and combined it under the movie
mode for the s35c
I still think that the TV looks best in
dynamic or standard
but it's your TV feel free to tweak the
settings to suit your taste in general
OLED displays have a higher tendency to
produce a black Crush effect this is
when darker parts of an image become too
dark and loose detail the extent to this
which happens can depend on factors like
the brightness of the room and the
content being displayed with a large
window by the side of the TV the issue
with glare and Reflections become more
apparent under bright lighting
conditions and this is a common problem
with many glossy screens in this case it
means that you may need to adjust the
lighting in a room or the TV is
positioned to reduce the effect of glare
and Reflections this is slushy
environmental and one will need to keep
that in mind whether TV will be
eventually placed in the living room
for the most part the TV looks great
from virtually every angle
with the s95c users will have greater
flexibility when it comes to how the TV
is eventually positioned from the front
the slim and small bezels is pretty much
part on calls for any OLED TV and it's
3840 by 2160 display
the real Beauty here is how tender TV is
from the side
one key change will be the inclusion of
the one connect box which is a handy
feature the last saw with the Samsung or
the cr55 inch monitor the wire connect
box now for overall neater cable
management and Slims down the profile of
the TV even more plugging in all the
various inputs into one place makes
reaching behind the TV outwardly a thing
of the pass you won't connect box as a
single keyboard that connects to the TV
display itself Samsung has been generous
in providing four HDMI 2.1 ports and 3
USB 2.0 ports as well which is key for
gaming Samsung is aware of the features
that PS5 and Xbox series X owners desire
such as Alm and vrr the TV is equipped
with these features to meet the demands
of Gamers if you are looking for g-sync
support you can stop holding a breath
instead we have freezing support once
again and while we would love the
possibility of using this TV as a
monitor its size just makes it totally
unfeasible which is a small PT
considering that the refresh rate of the
s95c is now at 144hz which the PS5 and
Xbox series X aren't really able to make
full use of so even if you have a
suitable GPU to match this display where
kept by technical specs of HDMI 2.1
technology which is a simple 120 hertz
at 4K
Tyson OS is once again back here in the
Forefront and he Powers the overall
experience for this Samsung s95c
if you're coming from other TVs the
curve in which one discovers and
explores the menus will definitely need
some time to get familiar with
once again all the major TV streaming
services can be found on tizen so
there's little concern that finding the
right content to enjoy the TV with would
be an issue with the one connect box
removing most of the bulk found on the
TV in terms of ports Samsung has been
able to focus its efforts on the
speakers which are now prominently
placed at the back of the TV while we do
recommend grabbing a Samsung soundbar to
make full use of the Q Symphony feature
which allows sounds from the Soundbar
and TV to be deployed at the same time
the existing speakers can get the job
done
[Music]
foreign
we've seen this remote before and it
looks like Samsung really likes this
design for those who are looking for
more getting used to this simple remote
might take some time to get used to
because it's so small it's going to get
lost in the couch sooner or later with
the s95b Samsung has put in a great deal
of effort into its own attack and over
the last year it had done well to win
over the critics ourselves included thus
the s95c coming in at a super size 77
inches shows that the company is
confident at its Builders and are
willing to place a big bet that this
range will appeal to well-heeled
individuals who might be willing to
Splash the cash for this purchase now
that Samsung's OLED Tech is no longer
the new kit on the Block The View
challenge here is to show how much it's
able to stand out from the competition
wallet willing the Samsung s95c is
certainly a large free buy for most
individuals but it will be one that
comes with minimal regrets
[Music]